this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
it is the bottom of the hour and we are
following breaking news this morning an
apartment fire
yeah still burning right now hector
mejia live right now at eastern sahara
where the situation is still developing
hector good morning to you
yeah good morning guys we just arrived
less than 10 minutes ago let's show you
what's going on right behind us people
at this complex here waking up to these
flashing lights here
what we can see from a distance here
this is the terrytown complex we have
las vegas fire and rescue as well
as metro police for a report of an
apartment fire here
we don't have too many details but
police are on the scene blocking some
roads within the complex
we don't know about any injuries but we
see paramedics standing by
clark county fire department on the
scene as well but that is what we can
see
from a distance now as far as road
closures it's not having a huge
impact in the area since it's happening
in this complex but again we just got
word about this
not too long ago on the scene we have
las vegas fire and rescue
metro police and clark county fire
department that's the latest we're going
to walk over across the street and talk
with firefighters for some more info
now let's talk about the road impact for
that let's go over to nate tannenbaum
nate
how's it looking out there all right
hector thank you so much so to get you
oriented and first of all the freeways
are in pretty good shape here so let's
zoom on down here we're talking about
the near east side of town
this is sahara this is eastern and the
fire is just
south of eastern just south of sahara
and just east of eastern here's our live
picture from the traffic camera
so there's one lane of northbound
eastern that is blocked at
karen so if you're on your way up from
d.i you can tell there's just not a
whole lot of traffic there right now but
there's still a lot of smoke coming up
so hector's over here on this side
looking across and he's going to check
it out for you and give you the latest
on that fire